[Music]
I'm drinking at this party maybe four
shots deep you asked if you can borrow
$5 for me at this point I'm drunk I
don't say yes or no I don't say anything
at all if you take $5 from me even if I
didn't explicitly say no you stole for
me we're standing in line for the
bathroom I asked you to hold my purse
while I go in if you take $5 from my
purse even though I trusted you to hold
it you stole for me I'm on a dark street
I feel a gun on the back of my head you
asked me for $5.00 again even if I
physically handed those five dollars to
you you stole from me we're out to
breakfast in your short $5.00 for a
coffee I lend it to you because we're
friends and because you asked me the
table next to us is short on cash too
and they saw me lend you money if they
go into my purse and assume they can
have $5 as well without asking they
stole from me a couple weeks later you
asked to borrow $5 again this time I
don't want to give it to you this time I
say no just because I let you borrow $5
before that doesn't mean you can take it
whenever you want if you take it without
asking you stole for me if you steal $5
for me but I can't prove it in court
you still stole for me whatever the
scenario you cannot take $5 from me
without my permission that's stealing
whatever the scenario you can't take my
body without permission that's rape
consent is simple
[Music]
you